so under the heading of stupid stuff
that's out there
I've seen some stupid stuff this is the
dumbest thing I've seen and I don't know
man so when you take out a loan on your
401k which you should never do when you
leave your company because you die
because you get a better job or because
they fire you you will leave your
company in other words but just when you
leave if you've not repaid the loan the
loan is considered an early withdrawal
and it's due in full if you don't repay
it in 60 days you get all the penalties
and all the taxes and so there's a new
financial wellness benefit out there now
called loan eraser so when you borrow
money your own money in your 401k if
you're dumb enough you can pay these
people a fee and oh gosh you can pay
them a big fee and they won't have
insurance for you that when you leave
the company or get fired from the
company it will pay your 401k
this is absolutely insanity because it's
insanity it's it's a really really dumb
idea to start with to go into debt on
your 401k to borrow your bar owe your
own money self back just your own money
back that's just nuts
but on top of that to turn on pay
insurance premiums to insure your
stupidity there these people know no
balance and instead of saying don't do
this instead of teaching people the way
we do stop it no we're gonna we're gonna
encourage it by insuring it you know 86%
of 401k loans default when people lose
their jobs 86% of 401k loans default
when people lose their jobs six billion
dollars in defaults annually which what
that means is you get paid you know you
borrow ten thousand dollars on your 401k
you leave you get hit with your tax rate
plus a ten percent penalty
so this is like a 35 or a 45 percent hit
on your money and so you're getting like
a $4,000 $3,000 smack in the face when
you get fired at 86% of the time that's
almost every time the people lose their
jobs they default on the 401k loans and
it becomes an early withdrawal this is a
bad idea
ensuring it oh you employers when you
put together your 401k don't even offer
the bar ability to borrow on the 401k
you don't have to offer that we don't
offer it here don't even offer it and if
you're gonna offer it for God's sakes
don't bring in a loan eraser oh this is
like it's like a stupid sandwich two
pieces of stupid bread and you make a
stupid sandwich two stupid things
together unbelievable gosh guys we have
got to start thinking somebody out there
at some point it's got to start using
their noodle
you just got to think you got to think
this is silly so you never borrow on
your 401 K if you're an employer don't
even offer it don't even offer it the
number of employers that we work with
with our smart dollar program which is
the program where we go in and the
employer educates all of their team
members and we show them how to cause
their 401k contributions to go up
dramatically and the borrowing to stop
[Music]
yeah when we go in that's what well you
know I'm gonna start telling them on the
station saying they stopped the number
of employers that have a serious problem
with people making contributions to turn
on bar on it back out contributions turn
around borrowing back out it's like a
like a dog chasing its tail
you gotta stop it people get a think so
just yeah don't don't take out insurance
on your stupidity that's a stupid
sandwich this is the Dave Ramsey show